je poursuis avec jean lapointe c'est
notre expert en aviation civile bonjour
monsieur lapointe
donc c'est la deuxième fois en six mois
que ce type d'appareil est impliqué dans
un écrasement
la dernière fois c'était en octobre un
avion de la compagnie line et on
indemnise et dans les deux cas c'est le
même type d'appareil donc boeing 737 max
8 qui s'est écrasé quelques minutes
seulement après le décollage donc est ce
qu'on peut penser que l'appareil est
encore au début de chaque enquête pour
des gens qu'il faut mener les enquêtes
l'avion est toujours en cause les
membres d'équipage sont toujours en
cause c'est au cours de l' enquête on
éliminera des points 2 qui nous amènera
à trouver la ou les raisons
sans vouloir être alarmiste aujourd'hui
ce que je trouve inquiétant c'est des
similitudes qui ont eu lieu avec ces
deux accidents c'est à dire vous avez
des avions neufs qui décolle dans des
conditions de vol excellente et qui sont
menés par des équipages compétents et
que dans les deux cas l'avion ne pourra
voler plus que douze et six minutes
aujourd'hui sans pouvoir prendre de
l'altitude
alors oui évidemment aujourd'hui on
pourrait dire que la pâte est un
problème là-dessus 37 max parce que ce
qu'on comprend c'est ce que les
autorités éthiopiennes ont dit ce matin
c'est à dire que l'avion a contacté la
tour de contrôle en disant que
l'appareil avait un problème donc on a
autorisé le retour à l'aéroport et c'est
là que ça s'est passé
oui lorsqu'on regarde aussi de lieu de
l'écrasement c'est très linéaire ce qui
me fait dire que l'avion s'était écrasé
que d'un seul morceau donc n'aurait pas
eu de perte de contrôle de vol avant
l'écrasement mai
le problème c'est que ce qui différencie
de boeing 737 max des autres familles de
7,37 c'est un nouveau système
automatique qui s'appelle le mcs qui est
la manyu veine caractéristiques
arment'hier chine système ce sont des
cendres qui sont à l'extérieur de
l'avion et qui sont branchés dans des
ordinateurs que l'on retrouve dans la
cabine de pilotage et le but de cette de
ce système là c'est d'empêcher d'avion
de décrocher et un décrochage en avion
on sait que ça peut être mortel c'est
lorsqu'il n'y a plus assez de vitesse
alors dans le code lyonnais le système
étant défectueux l'avion voulait
constamment à l'hiver le bord pour
reprendre la vitesse c'est les pauvres
pilotes eux se battait contre l'avion
pendant 12 minutes en tirant le mange
pour lui faire gagner de l'altitude pour
ne pas s'écraser
alors les similitudes de ce matin amène
énormément de doutes et de questions et
dans une industrie aussi bien rodée qui
va de la sécurité et rien à ces passages
il va falloir réagir très rapidement
d'ailleurs en avant mais une association
de pilotes aux états unis a réclamé une
meilleure formation pour ce type
d'appareil donc le 737 de boeing
max 8 alors meilleure formation et
meilleure information c'est semble-t-il
que même dans le manuel qui accompagne
ce type d'appareil on n'a pas toute
l'information voulue pour faire face à
ce genre d'un oui
l'association des pilotes de la
southwest airlines et d'american
airlines et de l'association qui
représente au dessus de 100 mille
pilotes a mentionné qu'ils étaient
inquiets suite au premier rapport
préliminaire de l'accident doit
ionnaires il était potentiel que les
pilotes n'ont pas été formés
adéquatement lorsqu'on est fort mais il
faut être bien informés au départ et
lorsque des associations de pilotes
parler ce qui est très rare ce sont des
professionnels
il faut les écouter parce que le premier
témoin d'un accident celui qui arrive le
premier sur cet accident ses pilotes ce
n'est pas l'administrateur
ce n'est pas le constructeur d'avions et
je pense qu'avec les similitudes avec
l'accident d'aujourd'hui
boeing et l'association l agence
fédérale américaine qui ont certifié
homologué l'avion sont imputables et je
pense qu'ils vont falloir il va falloir
disséminées tout doute est ce trop
puis demain on se contente d'un avion
qui est à la fine pointe de la
technologie et qui est populaire à
travers le monde d'un autre côté je
connais des commandes informateurs sur
cet avion là et puis ils ont aucune
crainte
c'est à dire qu'ils sont formés pour ils
comprennent ce que les ordinateurs de
vol leur dise parce qu'un pilote il faut
pas oublier qu'il est là pour piloter
comprendre ce qui se passe dans une
urgence et lorsque l'ordinateur est
rendu à penser plus vite que le pilote
l'interface entre l'être humain et
l'ordinateur n'est peut-être pas à
poindre à ce moment ci pour cet appareil
est ce que bon évidemment on est on en
est aux balbutiements de l'enquète mais
est ce que ces deux écrasement à
l'espace de six mois vont avoir un
impact pour boeing
je pense qu'ils vont de wii dans un dans
le sens qu'ils en ont déjà vendu plus de
5300 on à en livrer 350 à ce jour faut
pas oublier que boeing un excellente
réputation que ce soit avec leur boeing
très +7 7 8 7 et 17 37
alors cette nouvelle technologie là où
les ordinateurs de vol peuvent
potentiellement prendre une partie du
contrôle du cockpit
alors ça va falloir que ce soit
peut-être revu corrigé mieux informés et
mieux former les pilotes jean lapointe
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec notre
but
merci